let's play four
i didn't want to make four queens
unfortunately
i wanted to mate him so
okay let's try this knife to see trick
and h5 thing again
it worked last time so maybe it works
this time too
he has to go knight f6 squad h4
okay i'd say knight takes e4 is the best
move here
but for some reason people are not
playing like this before i don't know
why
it looks very obvious now
okay it took it okay so it takes
now i could show my preparation f3
takes knight takes so now i have some
compensation here
d4
bishop d3 knight g5 i think
he has some problems to
to defend his pawns here these pawns are
very weak i think
um 94
i like my position bishop t2 okay even
i think i have like some position here
like c5
okay let's go to keep one
and bishop c4
i'm trying to take on d6 and go bishop
before okay he takes honey for so now i
have
a very pleasant advantage here
g4 trying to
prevent the fight okay let's go h5
so he's going to be
he's going to suffer here i could say
that
bishop p3
let's try bishop c3
rook of one
yeah let's go d5 let's try d5 here
dc6 let's take on e6 angle
rook c4
i miss rook c8 but i think it's fine
look d1
i have a very pleasant position and
still i think
like he's going to okay he didn't even
take
so check what has designed the ambition
before
this is losing now yeah you could take
rook d8 to c
is hanging there rook d7 rook d4
and this is interesting
okay he resigned but he had some chances
with
d7 or rook before but yeah he was also
long time
[Music]
ah but maybe rook d4 could be seven
check and he
couldn't play looking easy so maybe it
was completely lost so
[Music]
okay good game anyways